[Music]
you have said that you believe people
have to work on psychic Ness or their
psychic abilities they have to train a
little it's like doing sit-ups or
something yeah exercising any part of
your body any any muscle it's part of
the brain and it yeah exercise I do have
if you would like to exercise your
psychic abilities I have a game we can
play that I bought at a crystal shop in
Los Feliz so it's totes legit weak and
try to open your chakras open my chakras
oh I'll give it a shot I have I don't
think I having any owls first yeah I
know well do you know what chakras are
first not really okay so chakras are
basically a series of energy centers
that run along the spine supposedly it
kind of in science would call it your
endocrine system they're different
glands basically okay I've got glands
alright so you can choose to energize or
activate any of the following chakras
and then we'll do this card game okay
your crown chakra that's at the top of
your head that's how you communicate
with the divine and right oh my god from
the Creator I've got an amazing antenna
your your third eye also known as a
pineal gland that's how you that's your
intuition and how you interact with your
environment on a subconscious or super
conscious level your throat chakra how
you speak the truth which is probably
good for you because you're in
communications and public figure heart
chakra that's self-explanatory solar
plexus is like self-esteem and then you
have sacral chakra which is also
referred to as the sexual chakra and
that's also self-explanatory but for
instance like if someone has an issue
with like premature ejaculation that
would show up in your sacral chakra if
you want to
who have you been talking to I get it
from the other I'm gonna go with the
sexual I'm definitely gonna go sexual oh
thanks not that I have an issue in that
area but I feel like very sexual right
now so there's these are my cards all
right you're gonna place the orange
chakra card face up in front of you okay
got it
that's the orange face in front of me
okay shuffle the remaining cards and
then line them up facedown okay so for
the remaining line them for face up face
up or face down face down okay okay now
you have two attempts to choose from
that pile of cards that's left to either
choose the red or the yellow card you
have to use your psychic intuition this
card be resting on my area that might
yeah but those are mine and you have to
give them back
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like there is that too much handy
that I go too far i I don't want any
part of this okay all right so this is
in my area and then I have two chances
to pick yeah you're trying to get red or
yellow okay those are the Shockers that
are above and below and sometimes you
can put your hands over and maybe it
heats up
maybe you view the cards and they
vibrate with the energy coming from here
or in a more sexual area there's all
kinds of stuffs happening should be
coming from there okay
I'm getting a lot of heat from this one
right here okay let's see what color it
is it's gray I don't know what color
that is that's the least sexual color oh
my god all right I'm not open it up open
it up okay okay open it up open your
chakra yeah my aunt spreading down here
will come to you
okay and I'm getting a lot of I'm
getting something from this one right
here green red
[Applause]
you